but we're going to begin with more
dangerous weather in the middle of the
country This Tornado was spotted last
night near Tyler Texas and there are
reports of damage across the state tens
of thousands lost power due to severe
storms now this comes as Oklahoma starts
the recovery after eight confirmed
tornadoes on Wednesday you heard that
number right guys eight they're linked
to three deaths and dozens of injuries
Omar villafranco joins us now from hard
hit coal Oklahoma boy they have been
through it Omar good morning to you
good morning Gail this is the kind of
damage that wind speeds up to 165 miles
an hour can do and look at this home The
Roof Is Gone the windows and walls are
blown out and there's debris spread all
over the place two people were killed
here in McLean County and residents now
are just trying to pick up their homes
and what's left of their lives
in Coal Oklahoma after an ef-3 tornado
tore through part of the Town Wednesday
night I was just trying to hang over to
your life Scott Curry said he was
holding on to his office door as winds
ripped through his home I had to hold my
wife's hand trying to keep her because
it was trying to suck her out
and uh I was just trying to hang over to
your life our team's working hard to get
the get all the local communities all
the support that they need nearly an
hour East Governor Kevin stid toured the
damage in Shawnee where winds as strong
as 150 miles per hour damaged almost
every building at Oklahoma Baptist
University we could feel the tornado hit
like we're in the basement and we felt
the ground Rattle and our ears were
popping no one at the school was hurt
but classes are canceled through the end
of the week yeah I mean it's just
unreal back in Coal we met Larry Paul
who wrote out the tornado with his
family in a storm shelter at his
mother's house they all made it out okay
record when I finally went over I didn't
want to look outside I didn't want to
see the devastation of everything yeah
that's material things but it's still
it's your heart
your family's worked hard for all this
one of the survivors here at this home
is actually a volunteer firefighter he's
the one who activated the tornado siren
in this area most likely saving lives
Crews have been working non-stop to try
to restore electricity that last check
just over 11 000 customers were still
without power Nate
and getting the power back is just the
beginning of a long road to recovery for
some Omar thank you